okay hello everyone welcome to a design
review
of some new functionality
for wolfram language
and this is about course making
um
and
oh okay
we're still building up infrastructure
form notebooks and question objects
okay
all right
so where do we start here
so we just heard
from john in a completely different
connection that he doesn't think form
notebooks are adequate so maybe we'll
learn something about that in this
meeting
okay so let's
go ahead so what are we looking at here
and whose wireframe is this
this is work
this is used wireframe this one is is
extremely simple
um this is whoever made the wireframe
here
yep yes i have here
okay
stephen i'd like to point out off the
bat that way there's another meeting
scheduled for streaming tomorrow that's
very related
so people who
it's more focused on question object and
the programmatic wolfram language design
of
an answer so so let me just let me just
set this stage here okay the purpose of
a form notebook is to allow people to
use a notebook
as an enhanced
form of form
in which you're entering
rich complex things like multicellular
inputs that will be effectively ingested
by a program just like in a an ordinary
form you would take things that you put
into fields
and those fields would be
inserted into you know through an
association
would be
uh you know fed to a function
a form notebook its goal
is to take rich objects including
effectively notebook content
and take those objects and be able to
feed them to a function
so that for example one could use a form
notebook as a submission mechanism for a
repository or something and collect
material for that
ready
so that it can be put
through perhaps a template notebook
into a final form in the repository
is that a fair summary of what what our
objectives are
yes and they could be used for all kinds
of things um
submission the report generation
yeah
right okay so
in version 12 3 we have an early version
of form notebooks right and we've
announced form notebooks and we've got
so if i do form new programmatic
notebook form authoring form notebook
authoring
then i will get something here which is
an authoring notebook for form notebooks
okay so now
what you're showing me here
is by by the way something i want to
point out ux is you when i go to 150
percent here
i would like to understand
under what circumstances we are
expanding infrastructure content and
when we are not
so for example from alpha assumptions
never get expanded when you expand the
notebook depends why you're expanding
the notebook whether that's a problem or
not
but i think we need to this is a quite
separate discussion
i think we need to um
have a
um uh
you know that's a ux
etc discussion about
how we specify whether you expand the
infrastructure elements
john fultz do you have a comment on that
yes i do uh yeah i would say that as a
general rule of thumb
uh
if what we're talking about is part of
the chrome
uh
then it's not subject to to
magnification
right
but but you know my question to you
would be let's go to 200 percent here
and let's say i say control equals
um
uh i don't know boston
okay
okay that's expanded now i go to the dot
dot dot
and oh it's micro
yeah yeah no there's there's a judgment
call to be made here um
and i'm not going to claim that
every judgment call so made is
absolutely correct well i think that
this could be correct it depends on the
circumstances i think that what's really
needed is
something slightly more subtle in terms
of magnification that says either
magnify only primary content or magnify
everything
so
one of the
pragmatic problems that we run into is
uh and that wouldn't be a problem with
this interface but
with toolbars uh when you magnify them
they get much more crowded
and
yeah you run into real problems things
overlapping one another well i mean that
can be simulated by making the notebook
narrower so i mean we've got to solve
that problem somewhere anyway
uh
it can be partially simulated not
entirely simulated
all right look let's not get let's not
derail this meeting but let's can we put
that on where should that be user
assistance
we can discuss any user assistance yeah
i mean i think it would be a thing
maybe christina could take a look at
where what magnifies and what doesn't as
a start for this
parth do you want to take that and
either for yourself or pass it to manu
uh yeah i'll just take it and get
working on it and we'll also talk look
at the accessibility
because
again yes this is a good accessibility
issue
um i mean i think in the end what it's
going to be
is some kind of
uh you know in the magnify thing there
would be a more button here that would
say magnify everything or don't magnify
everything you see what i'm saying or a
check box here magnify everything don't
magnify everything
you see what i'm saying yeah i
i i see what you're saying of course
you're you already know my gut reaction
to adding more options and decisions for
for things it's horrible yeah it's
horrible but i think but there are cases
in which you genuinely want one or the
other
like for for a presentation
you want to magnify everything typically
well except where you don't where it's
some sort of random password field okay
and and i should say like 95 percent of
the time when someone complains to me
about this
it's uh an internal person who was
trying to
you know demonstrate a feature on an
overhead
yeah exactly that's what it is
not necessarily just internal people but
anybody who wants to use us for that
okay let's go back to topic
okay so
what we've got
well i should say the reason i say
internal people is because it's often
features that one wouldn't bother to
demonstrate except to demonstrate the
feature itself i see
okay fair enough that one would just use
this piece of infrastructure basically
exactly exactly yeah like like the
predictive interface for example you
know one wouldn't normally use a
predictive interface in uh
uh right now
yeah yeah
okay all right let's set context here so
the thing we're about to look at the
wireframe for is part of the insert menu
is that correct
yeah why don't you go and insert a form
element
okay so i insert an input field
and add an additional field option
so the ux issue is after you add one
you don't have the option to remove it
okay well i mean john are you going to
blow up this whole ux
no actually i've i've reviewed uh
the ux's that we're looking at here so
um
okay so
and and hopefully
you know kept it sensible but you know
you'd be the judge what the hell i mean
addfield no we can't say that
this whole thing is a field what do you
mean it's not adding up what do you mean
add field
what what does that what does that even
mean what does that mean oh i see that's
another
what why are we doing this
no what the heck is this to add a field
you use form element and add another
field
why are we putting that inside here
that makes no sense
there's a brain disconnection
explain whoever created this explain
what that is supposed to be about
so um
so the thing is for one key element
there could be like in the code user can
actually have multiple fields
i'm sorry what the heck are you talking
right you you
like inside of a form object you can
have two inputs for example
yeah and for example wait a minute you
told me you were solving a different
problem you told me you were solving the
problem of there was a hint added
oh wait a minute oh my gosh you can't be
serious you can't be serious
you can't be serious
read the heading of this thing it says
input field right
it's an input field okay
you have put a button in here that says
add field
right
okay let's just do a little bit of a
think moment
why is that a bad idea
okay who can tell me why that's a bad
idea
gosh why do i need what is the field is
it field a big blob or is the field a
single
yeah we've everything's fields we're an
agricultural society yeah
i think soccer is a soccer thing oh okay
fine
the fall soccer
um
okay i don't understand there are two
different things we might want here
one is
this
which is very confusingly named to begin
with but
okay so
yeah i agree that is a confusing thing
okay so i don't understand what this is
supposed to be because this is now
adding a whole other input field which i
thought i was doing by pressing input
field to add an input field why am i
adding an input field inside this box
so
that was thinking of
the case
where
user might need to have multiple input
views for one question
but that's not how we do it
the whole point of that is you can have
as many input fields as you want what do
you mean by one question what are you
talking about what are you talking about
if you look at like the first example in
form objects
the first example is using two input
fields within the same form object first
like a first name last name you're
saying where you don't want to
vertically vertically i'm sorry i don't
know what are you doing what
yeah i'm not saying i agree with having
multiple fields this is just
unbelievably confusing we've got three
levels of fieldiness here
right we've got you insert an input
field it's got fields within fields okay
it's like
okay we've got a field within a field
here right this is a field within a
field
and this is now a field within a field
within a field
right and i don't understand what the
point of this is what is the different
functionality that you achieve by having
i this is crazy i'm sorry i don't think
it's completely bonkers to me
okay so hold on what is this now this is
a form object
what is the difference between having
this
as two separate fields
in the form notebook and having them
combined
and confused here is the point that
they'll be structured together in the
resulting data
no i don't think they are i think
they're structured by their names here
that what gets returned here is just
this thing here right
well presumably if you're doing if you
want to do something like this in a form
notebook
then the results from this would be
under the same key in the
like submitted association yeah but why
do we want that that just seems
unbelievably confusing
i mean we've already got
enough levels of confusion
right we don't need it nobody's asking
for hierarchical keys here if you want
hierarchical keys name the keys
hierarchically and you've got
hierarchical keys could you get this
behavior potentially by having a
compound element is the interpreter
uh so another really good example is
actually the check boxes
um
whereas actually you have
i don't have it your respect but but but
in a real example the check boxes
actually have the
different options and yeah well let's
take a look check boxes by the way
somebody's got that
something
wrong with their phone
okay this is not the same thing
no it's not the same thing
this is not multiple input fields in an
input field
do you understand what i'm saying
this is pieces of an element form
element that we know has multiple pieces
right because if you want to add d how
do you do it
add what if you want to add d right now
there's a b okay i understand that i
understand that but don't show me this
where we're adding input fields to here
no i i agree with that garbage guys
actually actually by by the way by the
way the uh
steven i would disagree with the
statement that you just made that this
is
multiple pieces of the same thing it
really isn't i mean the these are in f i
mean every checkbox is independent
oh really oh well then
it's it's radio buttons
oh yeah that would be mutually exclusive
right
a check but the whole point about this
is
format wise this is
this is formatted as a bar across the
page is that correct
and that's why you're putting them all
in the same box um
maybe i don't let's see uh
no they're not actually they're
formatted in a column
okay
but but
but we're returning from this
a
a single element on the right hand side
right
yeah
okay it'll it'll all be under the same
key
if that's what you're asking okay yes
that's what i'm asking right but so now
somebody has the bright idea which is a
new idea of having multiple input fields
in the under the same key is that
correct
how would be the how would the input
fields in your multi-input field thing
how are the input fields being combined
well i i mean i mean we we already have
this discrepancy i mean you know check
boxes
and input fields are different for no
good reason
well wait a minute what is this going to
return when i say label
it'll be
it'll be it'll be key one goes to
an association it's nested to an
association that's like a goes to true b
goes to false c goes to true okay
okay so you imagine in this case
that
you would have that label here for the
input field will be not the outer label
but an inner label
but what's the outer label of all of the
all of the family of input fields here
a little key one that's saying in the
bottom tab
okay
and so an input field normally doesn't
have a label is that true
when i just create what what is label oh
label one that is that people do have a
label they always do but that's just
what's displayed right it's not what the
it's not anything to do with the
association it's not the key
correct
okay so what what what is wrong here is
for
input for for it's not sorry it's not
the key but the label does appear in the
association okay okay okay i understand
but what you've done which is a hack
is
in check boxes apparently you're using
the labels for the check boxes as keys
in the association is that a true
statement
in on the second level
yes so that's a true statement so then
and it's the same for input fields
but no it's the same appeals in this
wacky approach here right now it is
right now
okay so wait a minute what's this key
here
that which
top level key in the association
okay and that has a second level key
that says label one is that right that's
correct
and and is label one both the textual
label and no that seems like the wrong
way to do it i mean who cares what the
textual label is you don't want to have
to modify your code yeah
i mean
in the textual label
maybe it might be a sensible default but
you would certainly want the option to
do things like you know put a graphic
there or something like that
yes and and then having the graphic be
in the you know the name of the key is
just absurd craze crazy
so wait a minute so there's an outer key
for the whole thing
and then there's an inner key for each
element is that yeah like that's
specifically to handle this
this
thing such a like things such as the
uh check boxes and whatever where you
have multiple
okay so in fact there's a mistake right
so this should be
this should be something that says
you know element key or something
right for these for these sub pieces
here and it can default to the label but
it can also say element separate key for
that element right
that's an option yeah i mean that's what
we have so yeah the thing is that
currently
like i was mentioning earlier is that
form objects can't like you can have a
form object that has multiple input
fields in it
notebooks use form objects and so there
has to be some way to handle this
okay thing where you have
you're addressing a different issue i'm
saying rip apart the fact that the label
for an element
is or a sub-element which is what these
really are the label for a sub-element
is the key for the sub-association
that's an incorrect connection
okay you see what i'm saying it could be
the default but it sure shouldn't be
what you have to do
right all right so what you've got here
is you've got an outer key
for for the main form element
and what you've got here are what we can
call sub elements
right these things here are sub elements
is that a true statement
yeah
okay so
what you've got is
you've got sort of an ad sub element
you know add one more of the same sub
elements correct
which you want to do for check boxes and
you say you want to do for input fields
as well
so what will happen is if you have only
one of it or alternatively strike
existing ones okay okay i i i didn't
want three check boxes i wanted okay
hold on hold on you've got a different
data structure that's coming back so is
it the case that when you have even a
single input field
that the payload that comes back
is outer key
arrow inner key arrow value that is
correct correct yes okay fine so
then so okay so then what's happening is
so whatever the key metaphor is for the
outer thing i think you should use the
same metaphor
for the inner object that is you are
labeling what's happening with a key
if everything needs a key
then it seems to me much clearer
to use
that same metaphor here either the key
is up there or the key goes with that
form element thing up here as a key over
here for example and then there's a sub
for each sub element there's also a key
right represented in the same kind of
way
does that make sense
i think
so i mean to me
yeah so what is the advantage of getting
so you're allowing two levels of
hierarchy that you're sort of
automatically setting up here that is
every time i put in a form element it is
a top level association element right so
those keys key one key two et cetera et
cetera et cetera those are uniquified
across the whole notebook
correct correct
okay so then
this
so then you're saying that each
form element
can again have multiple sub elements
with their own keys correct
and in fact always does so
correct yes
okay all right so then these should be
indicated some other way
i i'm not sure i had ever understood
that
okay so
this is spectacularly wrong i'm sorry i
i really i'm sorry i just this is the
kind of thing that makes kind of like
steam come out of my ears about ux okay
it's like
you know this wasn't thought about you
can't have something that says add field
to a thing that's already saying it's an
input field
well yes well
and really really we don't even
you know we can just have uh you know a
plus
um i mean it's it's a list you you know
you plus to add to the end of the list
that's
it doesn't need to be anything more than
oh it doesn't need to say field but i
mean the okay
okay
but this is completely and utterly gosh
this is so confused
oh my gosh you've really messed this up
i'm sorry
okay let me let me make a criterion okay
when i see one of these ux designs what
should happen is
it should not be more confusing than it
was but to begin with
and it should not be the case that in
you know a fraction of a second i can
tell you that it's wrong
please don't make me do that
um so yeah so the uh the initial goal of
this add field button
was
coming from because if user wants to add
another field especially for the check
box to have to go to the code okay let
me just let me just give you
my
point of view about ux okay i expect you
to think
right by the time you're showing me
something where in a fraction of a
second i can tell you it's wrong
that's not the right thing
yeah i do understand that
okay
what else are we looking at here so so
the way that we've we've defined this
with um like the top-level keys sub-key
sub-elements
i think that that's going to help the
way forward on this one i think that we
should go to the next agenda item
okay all right but but but just to be
clear here we've got two completely
different i mean so confused it's just
outrageously confused
what are you doing here what the heck
are you doing
this has to do with adding things like
masking to the field right this has to
do with well are you just completely
confused about what this does
i just don't get it
please don't put me through this part
this is it's an important thing just
yeah we'll make sure this doesn't happen
again steven
we'll take a look and make sure you
don't get that stuff anymore
yeah i don't want to i i never want this
to happen again this is what happened
with hyperlinks we had to go through
like eight meetings with me i'm
exaggerating it was probably like four
of unstoppable confusion complete
confusion
we can't have that
okay
all right so you've confused here
something to do with adding a mask for
example here right with adding a
complete new sub element
am i right that you confused that
i
have just moved that to the oh no you
haven't moved it no no no he did
in the blue box there so i didn't remove
it it's just okay but that's completely
a stupid place to put it since we just
had a sequence of these things here and
we're adding a new one of those
so if we're done undressing this ux can
we just move on to the next agenda item
no because i want to actually get the i
don't want you to come back with another
piece of stupid ux and have me have to
fix it again let's just nail it right
now
you don't think it's nailed
no it's not nailed okay okay there's two
different things here
right
on the next one down where you have
input field one and footage field two
you're very thankful we can barely hear
you
is that better yeah the thing where it
says remove field is that referring to
an option or to a sub element
that refers to the sub element for the
option because it's got a separate
remove field up here right it's sort of
confusing i mean it's probably just
because we're using the word field
everywhere but
that'll be next to additional option
fields
seems like they're related and they're
not okay so
okay
okay
okay so look
additional option fields
we called it that not thinking of the
input field case
right
we need to have
the terminology of sub elements seems to
be fairly helpful here right i agree but
this is so
okay edit
okay then we can say
somewhere down here
add another sub element
add a sub element
and but the key for this sub element has
to be indicated somewhere
well i mean we can't say form element
and then sub elements
edit this form element i think we could
say i mean it's a form sub element i
don't think we have to say form again
but but i want to know where we put the
key
associated with this sub element
right that's the key for the whole form
element
and to me it will be nice to associate
that key with the thing that says form
element here you see what i'm saying
given that we have sub elements
right
i mean this is fine if we have no sub
elements it's fine to attach it here but
if we're going to have sub elements
we're going to have something where the
the key for the sub elements
is indicated in a completely different
way from the key for the whole form
element
makes sense
and that's not right
um just had a color that all the keys
you know the key tab at the bottom and
the key
fields in the
in the body
share some sort of color
nick is commenting that why is there a
hassle about form elements have multiple
input fields because it's utterly
confusing
and j3 is commenting contextual menus
will come in handy
the problem with the contextual menu is
nobody knows it's there
it's not discoverable
okay i mean we could have things on
hover but i think that's again very
confusing
okay so hold on
there is a key
for
um
there's a key for the whole
form element
right
and there is a key
and sometimes quite often you never need
to worry about what that key is so we
don't want to put it in your face if you
don't need to worry about it
um
sorry why don't we need
to know what the key is because it'll
just you just see what it produces and
then you write code around it
in other words
if it's just oh i just want a bunch of
values you just get the keys that key
one key to key three and you just say
values of that and then you're happy
person
it's only for yeah you don't want to
have to worry about sub sub keys
well not only sub keys but also keys
them top level keys okay let's go
through this again okay so what we've
got well i feel like you need to care
about
some key because you need to be able to
differentiate
um sometimes you don't if you're just
taking it i mean you know unless your
form only has one
uh one field in it yeah all right right
fair enough okay so
one possibility
okay so we've got a key for the form
element and we've got a key for every
sub-element so every sub-element here i
mean we could as well have something
that
has
just a field called key here
right
that's yeah that's what i was proposing
and maybe give it a special color and
have it match the color for the tab
at the bottom that's the key the whole
thing it's possible
but then the defaults would be which we
think is a useful default is to have the
label and the key be the same thing
in which case maybe we lead with the key
and just like we do for interpreter
you know in a form in a form function
by default
the the prompt is the same as the name
of the object so i think that's what we
should do well
frankly in that case you know we can
um uh
you know omit the label from the default
listing entirely exactly exactly the
label can be fields
like label you can set it to be none and
then there won't be a link okay okay
okay okay guys guys guys no no no it's
what i'm suggesting is that the uh you
know the automatic value would be the
same as the key exactly right so the
first element here says key
not label and you get to add a label if
you want to
in you got what i'm saying yeah and and
then you're 80 or 90 of time that will
be what you want but you do want to be
able to override it right in fact the
correct this is this is the right thing
to do because exactly how form function
works
form function is exactly you know x
arrow boolean or something that's
exactly how it works and the default is
to use that x as both the key and the
prompt
and and as people say add additional
sub-element they should be filled in
with unique values automatically then if
you don't care you don't care
and you can just wrap everything in
values on the back end
yeah
yeah well
wait wait a second you're talking about
different things so what i'm saying is
change this
so that when you add a new form element
yeah the first thing says t here and
there's an additional thing called label
which is i believe the language we use
for form form function yes that's
correct that's correct okay i'm on the
same page as you yeah yeah you and bob
are green yeah i'm just saying i'm just
saying some like we said some people
don't care about keys or sub keys
because they're just pulling out values
and they're using which position
so your point is so automatically
pre-populate them with unique values
that are short okay fine but what are
they going to be maybe they should be in
gray before you type them in otherwise
people will be confused i mean we could
call them
uh
item one or something well it's i mean
if
you know you use consistent language
you know if if you're calling it if
you're calling these things sub elements
then sub element one sub element two i
don't know if that's the right name but
it seems like the language should be
consistent though
unless we call them items would items be
consistent with anything we're doing in
in grids and things
well an item is a thing used in a grid
but i don't think there's necessarily
confusion though it's
you know there's there's enough distance
between that and this i don't think they
get confused
i don't know whether item helps i you
know the problem is by the time we're
talking about sub elements it sounds
like category theory or something
i mean it sounds very complicated
it does yeah
i agree with that all this sounds
reasonable to me i just still have one
question which is
how does it
like if you choose a key does it display
that key as the label of the
field exactly okay okay that's exactly
the same thing that form function does
yeah and it works well yeah
i mean the other possibility is leave
the key blank
initially i don't think filling in a
default key is a very good idea
we don't want it it's annoying honestly
just leave it blank and if you say
confirm with that key being blank it
says
and complains
right it just says it's a required field
big deal
there are lots of required fields
okay so that's what i suggest we do for
that now
where does that mean
um
okay so now we have to if
if it's blank we should at least have
have hint text though oh yeah sure
that's fine
but it's going to say key on the left
anyway
we can have a question mark thing okay
that's not dealing with how do we deal
with
this
probably less essential
um
well maybe we can leave this for now
this this outer key here it's a little
bit confusing
um
and then we would say
new sub element
at the bottom here we would say add sub
element
right which is which would add another
one of these
i think this has got to be called key
i just think it's way too confusing to
call it nothing other than key and then
it might suggest that we call this
somehow
for this form cell what the heck is the
difference in form elements in a form
cell
i think that it should be consistent
yeah it should be consistent
okay so then
look i think what we should do is is
label this as form element key
perhaps have what we do
is
i know we wanted to make this subsidiary
but if we call that form element key and
this just key here
that's a key for this
well i mean i i i would have referred to
you know
i don't know how this is presented in
the interface but i would have
referred to the outer thing as uh as a
form key and the inner thing maybe as an
element key
we shouldn't say form key because the
whole thing is a form
we've got a form of that okay well we
can call something
that's what i mean you know what what
are the top level keys in a form
i think they're form element keys i
really don't think they should be called
form keys because i think that's going
to make it make it more i don't think
that's understandable
i'm sorry are we going to call anything
a field
we can't call everything a field but we
could call one thing a field i'm not
sure we want that i mean
um okay let's look at i think form
element is a fine name
so i think
if we called it form element key and had
it over here
and had it indicating that it's for the
whole thing i think that will be
reasonable
form element key and have it be some
kind of
some kind of field like that that you
enter it into
now do i profoundly worry about whether
it's the bottom or the top we could i
think it would be better at the top to
go along with this because we have and
then what i would do
is have a separator
even at the top there
to indicate that there could be multiple
sub elements here so that you don't you
know so this
becomes the header for this whole blue
box no it we don't need a separator
well uh maybe maybe i think we could do
at least more space and i think a
separator wouldn't be better but but but
but definitely i mean if if we take my
idea of of a separator and then a plus
you know a plus button below it yeah
then it would i separated with a plus
button below that would be
a straightforward way to add and a mouse
over there that says when we don't
really need to name these things
then it's pretty obvious that you're
going to get another one of these
wait so form element key is that the
label that's used in cases that don't
have sub elements
i i don't know what element no no no sub
elements everything has a form element
key and it has a key
that's an item key but you only need to
like both if you have sub elements right
but but we're giving you both in all
cases the structure of the data doesn't
change based on whether or not you have
multiple sub elements
it makes it more confusing if that's not
common right in an input field case
single input field case
sub elements is yeah it i could see it
being confusing the first time you ever
use it but after that say that again
just having it so i've got a single
input field and i want to submit the
data and know what what it is person's
name or their last name
i know and you've got so so which thing
labels the first name or last name or do
i have to name two things you gotta name
two things
it's very grotesque yeah you've got two
levels here and that's what they've set
up
and i think that's the only thing we can
set up here because i think everything
else i mean i personally the fact that
we have these sub elements seems kind of
stupid to me
given that i mean why do we have sub
elements at all
you need them for radio buttons that's
that's clear but i'm not sure why do you
need them for radio buttons radio
buttons are is amazing no no actually no
no you don't let it take a look at
steven go ahead and insert a radio
button and you'll see why you don't
actually need it
yeah
oh
check box definitely no you don't no no
no you don't each checkbox is
independent
so when do you need multiple elements
because it it confuses everything
in the current in the current design of
the checkbox form
if you want to add one more field user
no i'm asking what's the case where
somebody's gonna want this feature first
name last name
why do you need that why don't you just
have a first name
yeah is it a layout because you want the
data i want the data to be structured on
the back end probably no no wrong don't
agree not a good reason to make this
more complicated right right the the
case of people who have hierarchical
forms they can make the forms
hierarchical by making the keys
hierarchical
see what i'm saying
does that give you a side-by-side layout
is that a reason nothing gives you a
side-by-side layout at this time on the
web but i guess not in a notebook right
right so the question of side by side
layout
to me that's a separate thing and that
could be done with directives you know
because we are going to author the thing
in a sequential layout
i mean you know the only
the two reasons i can see for supporting
sub elements uh
and i'm not saying these are strong
reasons but they're reasons uh
one is
uh you know because they're all put in a
single cell there's there's a certain
visual grouping that you get for free
when you're doing that
uh
the and the second is um
uh
the sorry what was the second i'm sorry
my mind blanked there uh i did have
another reason but my mind blanked
and you could also get around the need
to have the sub elements in the
authoring notebook if we let people put
a compound element as the interpreter
it wouldn't be quite really
oh sorry sorry the the second reason is
just because of the tediousness of
constantly you know
uh pulling up the forum element pop-up
or you know no you're hitting these
things you know so it's i'm not saying
it's a strong reason but there is there
is a we're putting them right here
you've got a new input field you put it
here let's get rid of sub-elements you
guys have not made a compelling case for
them
yeah i'm the one arguing i'm the one
arguing strongest first and i don't even
really want them
right yeah and that's the way we can get
rid of the obscurity of having this
separate key here
i don't know i don't want them but it's
possible to type a form element with sub
elements i think that we just have to
have you know better parsing of the code
to say you can't do that
right i mean if something yeah i mean
the code
so that's not the way we solve the
problem is by the if if there's
something that you can specify
programmatically that we do not have a
ui for so be it right can we have code
that somehow grays out the template we
know it's not template supportable and
okay gray that button out yeah and then
we just have the code version yeah
that's all we have
that's a good idea
okay all right so we're ripping out
sub elements
yeehaw okay
and
what's going to happen is
and we're ripping out this down here
and that's just going to become key up
here
right
just like a form function
am i making sense yeah i mean you could
still have a separate label than a key
right absolutely that should be under
the addition yeah it should be uh right
but yeah
and okay so now the question is and do
we know what the code form of of one of
these new things is
because that's going to be one level
because that's something that i hadn't
realized and probably
probably influenced this this whole
uh design in the first place is that the
the the code form is a form object so
it's like
you know this in in a way this parallels
form objects
this this sub key design
yeah
well but form objects don't require a
sub key
form objects allow a top level thing so
i don't know what we're doing with the
with a
sub key there uh okay okay i didn't know
that i'm not a form object expert so
right so we should the the
okay the nested form object case
is a corner case as far as i'm concerned
and it's not the thing that that wags
the whole ux
am i making sense yeah i think by
relegating it it makes it a lot more
straightforward okay so then we've got
one additional thing we have to figure
out which is okay so we've got two
things first of all the x the hover x
to delete a field
fine
right hover you get an x you delete the
field that seems okay to me now the
question is how do you get an additional
option field
if we still want to keep the existing
one here
that still works
i'm sorry
like we still have the additional
options right now in this interface and
that is where i know i know i'm i'm
addressing a different question which is
is that the right name for it that the
operation is fine oh this is doing is
fine
and do we still want it to be in the
same location yes
yep yes there's no problem with it the
problem is this unbelievable confusion
with sub elements
could you say instead of additional
option fields could you say specify
additional options
yeah
additional options dot dot dot
yeah that's better just get rid of the
word fields that's it's just that's the
confusing part
except that they're not options you know
yeah that's that's where we kept running
into it and in the form object page
they're called elements but we say
insert form element and so
what are they can we see the list again
they're options what are how are these
not options because option means blah
arrow blah in a function and these are
not that so
in the the definition of option in
mathematica yeah yeah right so just use
a lowercase
right
oh
i think people understand these as
options right
lowercase options
so we just say more options dot dot dot
yeah i i
maybe you won't like this but i mean i
like the
apple mail design in in the compose
window
which is you know it's a simple icon
that's i think comparatively easy to
decode
just uh bring up a new mail um
which one uh it's uh uh yeah it's it's
to the right of the
uh of the uh sorry on the left side to
the right of the send mail yeah there
you go
yeah that's perfectly possible
i mean the iconography lends itself to
here's a list of things and you're
adding or removing from that except
everything is words here
i mean we could just have that icon and
then say more dot dot dot
then i think that will be fairly clear
the icon indicates what it is yep
all right okay let's move on i think
we've got a solution here yeah go ahead
small pics could we not so edit this
form element could we change that to
gray or black but not blue it looks like
a link to me because everything
clickable is blue
and then
in addition change form element to
specific to the thing it is i'm not
seeing input field or radio box
that's a good point edit this input
field or edit this exactly good point
good point
yeah good point
okay
um
there have been some comments on our
live stream here
uh
um
it's properties
suggesting attributes or properties all
of which well
i i don't think i think i think we've
got a good solution with just the icon
and the more
um
okay let's move on that was not a happy
moment
but what's next in the agenda
ux of the settings dialog um choosing or
customizing submission actions
uh for this even i will mention i think
it's uh it's too much to ask users to
add that many uh submission options we
should start with two data bin and email
and really work those cases down and
then add another
i don't agree with you
i mean i don't agree
you know i'll tell you why
i'll tell you why the most important
reason
for create local notebook is so you can
debug what an earth you're doing
if you have to if the only way to tell
what you're doing is to go look at your
email
you're very confused
do you see what i'm saying i'm not even
entirely certain what to expect from
create
notebook whether local or cloud it just
pops up
preview mode
shouldn't you be able to preview like
you should have to create a submission
to check your work
but you do have to because no but but
the problem is that once you've created
a notebook a non
once you've authored a form notebook
what happens after that
is
um
you see what i'm saying you no longer
have you no longer are connected to the
authoring environment
see what i'm saying
this is all gone by the time you're
actually submitting a notebook through
the form
form notebook mechanism
okay
let's see all right i mean so create
notebook creates one notebook for each
response
yeah
no no let me explain let me explain
okay you author a form notebook
okay
then
when you
that
and this is something
okay then you can have multiple
instances of that form notebook
no that's not right you you you author a
form notebook you create the the form
that somebody is going to fill in
somebody fills that form in then they
press submit
and then something else is generated
from that
so it's a three-step thing first you
author no no no i i i get that my
question is what happens uh when it's
done for a second time
does it does it create
uh
you know separate notebooks for each
response oh you mean aggregation
single notebook wow it creates a
separate cloud note a separate local
notebook for every response every time
you fill out every time you press submit
it will create a new document
right every time you press submit it's
like i'm requesting
a new
you know delivery of a of a new platypus
or something
it's got a separate um
uh you know it's a separate
you know manifest so to speak gosh that
i mean i'm
you know aside from the see what it did
i'm struggling to understand the utility
of that
oh i'll tell you what i'll tell you what
what's useful about it okay let's say
that what you're doing is you're using
this
to
uh you
want to produce something in fact i've
needed this a bunch of times okay so
here's the thing you're doing some
i don't know um
you're going to do a s
okay
okay here's here's a use case
i've got
i'm creating a series of computer
experiments
each one
has certain parameters
okay
i'm going to run them
by i'm going to fill in the parameters
i'm going to use the form notebook to
you know to set up the experiment
the result of my experiment is a bunch
of specimens right there's a notebook
full of specimens
and that's the thing that i want that
i'm then going to do something with
myself
i'm then going to it's going to be
that's that's my end product in other
words i'm using
okay so so you might ask the question
sorry
i mean it sounds like you're you're
putting together
form notebooks and template notebooks
well i know i know i don't expect form
notebooks to do computation i expect
form notebooks to scrape data
what if you're going to take the
resulting association and put it in a
piece of code
which is fine but you don't actually
specify or you shouldn't actually
specify that in a form notebook
but how would you specify it what how
would you do it that's the point of the
custom thing here
in other words what we're saying is
in a template notebook
you have the structure of the notebooks
i mean i mean you're you're you're
making a template notebook feature
that's not template notebooks
and some seems like to me
well yes and no why would you do that
yes and no
yes and no a template notebook is
layout first you are creating a template
notebook specifies a template of the
final layout you want
okay this does not do that
this has no layout defined in its it is
simply splitting out
a collection of data
okay and but what i'm saying and what
you're saying which is correct is when
it splits that collection of data one
thing i might want to do with that
collection of data is feed it into a
template notebook to have that data
formatted in a nice way that will be a
role for a template notebook the
question is is there a need to have the
limp unformatted
kind of
you know just pure his pieces of data in
a notebook version of that
which i've certainly found useful for
debugging this
i mean even even for debugging i think
data bins are beautiful for this
why how do you view it see what what i
want is look i'm trying to write my form
notebook okay i say
you know
i mean you just go to the web page for
the data bin and look at it i know but
but you don't want the web page you want
a notebook because you're because no no
in fact that is profoundly wrong okay
and here's why the whole point of a form
notebook is that you can put notebook
content into it
saying go to a web page to look at
notebook content it's crazy
right you you've got singing dancing
notebook content you want to be able to
make use you want to be able to look at
that the place where you want to look at
that that's in natural places either a
local or a cloud notebook
i agree with that but question the the
one notebook at a time as opposed to
like a log notebook where you're
submitting to the same file appending or
something to it each time um
i think creating an untitled notebook is
the right thing to do
for your use case but but say somebody
that makes a form that's local and they
want to submit their data somewhere
why not submit it to another well okay
that's a different then you're asking
for another option here maybe
like local file or any file it could be
a file on a network or somewhere
yes well that's a reasonable thing too i
think there are already too many options
uh you know it's well i can i can barely
understand the ones that are here okay
look look
and this is
go ahead
what i said was we should start with two
i didn't say we should not have the
other okay but we have more than that we
have other things working we have this
working right guys
yeah it's already working
so we're not starting with anything
we've already got it so i think we need
to keep custom
all the time
yes
it should always be there yeah yeah but
but i mean if we've already got it we
shouldn't take it away
i don't think that's the right answer no
no this is not a place where complexity
matters that much the question in a
pull-down like this is is there an item
that does exactly what you want if yes
you're a happy person if no you you are
frustrated
right so having fewer items is not
valuable here it is valuable when it's
at the top level and you're looking at
this whole page like this
then it might be valuable to have fewer
options
do you see what i'm saying
but in the pull down it doesn't matter
plus we've already built them
okay so let's let's look at the rest of
this page is that what we're looking at
what are we looking at this is not the
right page because you're actually on
the third page that actually includes um
i'm sorry so what is the right page i i
just clicked
on the hamburger menu on the top
um the first page is the one up there
yeah
that's my fault sorry
okay so what is the point here
what are we looking at on this page so
if you go down to if you move down you
will see actually we have
specified we have so initially in the
current implementation if user wants to
specify send via email or submit the
data being they have to write code
which
it's considered okay hold on hold on
hold on so the problem we're trying to
solve here is in the current version so
if i say if i go to the current version
here and i go to what do i go to right
settings to gear menu
okay and i say here
um
submission create document send email
yeah
god's sake put a space after the comma
is this does this really need to be that
illiterate
what is this anyway what is this
right it just gives you a lot of code to
edit but it's like no but what is this
what is it even doing what is this code
even doing
the slot is the association generated by
the form notebook yeah so the customer
why is this saying to string why does it
need the two string it doesn't need the
two string
try using send mail it doesn't need the
two string
it'll rasterize it otherwise really
yeah if you put an arbitrary expression
instead of a string but can we please
put a space there so that we're not
illiterate yes
and you know the fact that it doesn't
have a space there
is a big signal that i never looked at
this
did this ever get design reviewed
that is actually what we are changing
here no no no i'm not talking about
changing i'm asking the procedural
question did this get design reviewed
and that's not why not yes yes you
looked at this list of things i don't
think i don't know that we went through
every single one of them with you right
okay but you provided this list of
submission actions okay fine all right
so now
what you're trying to do here is to
provide a gui as an alternative to this
code is that correct
yes
okay
and why do we think that's important
because we have a gui for everything
else this is this is supposed to use our
experience okay okay i mean i
would have thought it would have been
obvious in this case okay all right okay
okay but so but john you've made the
statement
that
the form notebooks are unusable
well i mean i i mean i mean here here is
an example right here you know in the
current implementation um
like just knowing that you have to use
slot is like you don't know that you
know
no no no no look look look
look okay
the question is what is the cost of
making a gui for this
okay i mean if this feature is never
going to be used we shouldn't make waste
the time to make well well i totally
agree uh
you know which is which is why i
question
you know the items that we put in the
list but
i figured the email was probably a
fairly desirable item okay all right
okay so let's go back and look at that
for a second here okay so so the what
we're trying to achieve is
instead of having code there
we are we have so what you're proposing
here is where is the email where's the
where is the thing that's proposing
this is
anybody looking right at it okay so it's
a pretty strange interface isn't it that
this is a pull down which seems like
you're just setting something and then
it extrudes a different thing here isn't
this isn't that not the usual way that's
done
when you're going to have something
uh
what is this store the submitted
response what are you talking about what
are you talking about what is that
what is that
well i mean the question is the question
what is that
what are you talking about when you hit
the okay submit which is why it says
what to do with the form data here
it seems like a pretty clear thing to
say
whereas this one i can't even understand
and with response collections what the
hell does that mean what does that mean
what does that mean what does that word
mean what does it mean
what does that heading mean
explain who wrote that heading and what
does it mean
so for the
coat we are actually having three
separate things the first one is the
message dialogue that is up as a section
and the next one is
okay this is garbage this is garbage
this is garbage
no this is incomprehensible garbage
properties of submissions what do you
mean by that
you mean what's going to happen when you
press the submit button is that correct
is that what you mean the setting makes
sense the sub heading submission button
action that makes sense that's fine
right there yeah i don't know why we
even need the one above it
that response collections is part of
that group
right what does it mean what is it i
don't know i'm just saying that's why
it's
part of that heading but that's a lower
level message is part of it and response
collections is probably yeah okay
so basically what we really want is to
make submission button action
okay properties of j okay okay okay so
the point here is
properties of authoring notebook
okay
so that's one thing
properties have generated form notebook
okay
okay so we probably should say here we
imagined that we would have more stuff
so we should say
what is a generated form notebook
someone in the chat said this thing is
too tall and i kind of agree i wonder if
this should be two different
menus two different dialogues i'm not
even sure why you need the properties of
generated form notebook
because customize the appearance of the
notebook that you potentially send out
all over the world yes that's what
that's what it is this is isn't that
what style sheets are for
no because this is i mean well
we have if we haven't gotten you to make
a style sheet yeah then that would put a
button right here that launches the
style but i do think this should be
closed by default this could say because
this is an obscure thing
let them customize the 10 things most
people want to customize with a simple
gui and not
infinitely right but we've already built
this so we might as well have it we can
close it
okay
i don't agree with that philosophy
look look no no no no wait a second this
is stuff you need you need to know what
does it say on the submission button
right that's an example of something you
need
okay i didn't even realize that was an
input field i no i know i see it's not
clear at all
right well i thought i i thought it just
allowed you to choose the button color
the submit button
i didn't realize you could actually
change the text of submit it that was
right okay well fine so this is probably
badly set up
so
look
possibly what this needs okay if there
was a picture
of a sort of
okay
we've got several things here
okay
okay this is a settings dialogue and
maybe we should break these settings up
maybe this is super confusing
okay
and by the way the analytics is in the
wrong section
no not necessarily the reason that it's
there is because we we we want to
eventually have analytics like how long
someone was doing the test and stuff
like that it's a property of the
submitted data though
it doesn't have anything to do with the
generated four notebooks okay first
point
let's break this
at the level of the this
and maybe we should just call it
uh settings or something here and rather
than that obscure you know because this
is a pretty important thing
let's have a button there possibly even
with an icon you know with a gear and
then the word settings okay
and then
what we can do is there are different
kinds of settings okay
so there's authoring notebook generated
notebook
uh submission button action
okay
okay
yeah
does the numbering happen at the time of
generation or could it happen beforehand
i wonder if that could just be no no no
no that's nothing to do with that the
key numbering is something different
yeah i i mean i mean right i know i
understand what the key numbering is i
just wonder if it should be a button in
the toolbar instead of in the settings
menu and then it would happen when you
pushed it instead of at the time of
generation yeah i i i mean and then
having it as a checkbox and having it as
the very first thing you see
in a dialogue that you have to interface
with
is is is bad it kind of is fair
i mean it's it's you know it's it's like
you know a pimple on a pimple sort of
thing and we made it the number one
thing
okay so explain even what this is what
are you proposing for the key numbering
thing
just have it be a button and we have a
toolbar it's an action not a property
in tools right in tools and then
whenever you push it it renumbers them
so
yeah it doesn't happen at the time of
generation it wasn't numbers
but doesn't it i see otherwise it never
does it right if you're copying paste
and moving around then it you need to
have a process sorted all out for you
and and by the way it's totally
confusing to have an authoring notebook
with different keys than a generated
notebook and that's
that's a result of it being a property
are we auto numbering keys anymore i
thought we decided we're going to make
them
label their key
we're going to make them label their key
so yeah no no no no no i'm sorry no
we're labeling
keys the first field and it's also the
label
you're absolutely right right so there's
no auto number so the check button
should just check that they're all
unique and then you're done
right
right
and that's an irrelevant so we just get
rid of this
yeah
also does this dialogue have to be one
scroll view or could be separated out by
no we're separating it we're saying
we're already agreeing
settings and it's going to separate
settings
you know
uh
you know dialogues
okay
right like a notebook styles and uh you
know
submission action
which is just the layout like a tab
view yeah so like we're doing with the
new preferences no no no no i'm not
suggesting i'm suggesting that the
settings is a pull down here oh
that goes to either submission action
or
which i think is the right thing to say
submission action
or
this thing here about
previously you'd said submission button
action
i know i think submission action makes
sense though all right
and then
what is this
what is this docked cell thing
that's the text in the header like on
the left side
yes it's the form title right and the
default should probably not say generate
form you should probably say like hell
no it should be my blank or black
right so so this is
okay so hold on
i mean that's two different things but
but we don't need a title at all
i mean it's free form content you can
just insert a title
no you can't no you can't remember you
can you're typing command one title i
see i see it no it's in a dark cell yeah
but
we don't i mean
we don't even forcing that there's a
submit button there yeah we want this
well if the submit button doesn't need
to be in a doc cell
i mean the submit button could be
you know in an attached cell attached to
the upper right corner of the window uh
it's you know
uh
if you want a doc sell that's fine but i
i it's certainly not necessary
okay fine
then
this question this is awfully confusing
then so i mean the main thing is you can
paint a different you know what is the
submission button supposed to look like
that needs to be specified here
right that's the only thing that's
involved in this
and you know you're not even putting in
here you know what about all kinds of
hints and mouse overs and so on i mean
you presumably want the ability to put
code for that
right which we're not providing here and
we probably should
as a as a kind of a i mean you know as a
kind of i mean
maybe we don't give too many options but
we just say this is what it says
i just think you do need to be able to
paint something different on the button
than just the word submit
you know
i mean you can i know you put it there
but i mean but but you know order your
aardvark now
i wonder if they're endangered species
they may not be orderable um
they uh
in any case
um
no but but you see what i'm saying that
this you gotta have some way to give an
option for what the button looks like
but it didn't need to be this elaborate
okay so that's thing number one and then
the submission actions
here
then you're saying we want guise for
these submission actions so let's just
take a quick look at the proposed gui
for this
okay
after we've after we've thrown out the
word response collections as being
just
mind-bogglingly meaningless i i'm not
just playing stupid here i do not know
what that could possibly mean
for those people who are responding to
the form this is how you collect those
responses i mean it's not the right word
collections plural what does that mean
well they're potentially if in the cases
of like a quiz there's more than one
response to this
uh but it's
a collection
and why is that
just procedurally for us something for
path
that was text we didn't write why isn't
it in curly braces
do you understand what i'm saying yeah i
no i think it should have been it should
have been in curly braces
but i don't even know what the thinking
was about whatever i'm not even going to
go there okay all right so
okay send via email all right so then
something
this is not the right ux to have
something extrude you know this has got
to be a more heading type thing that
then makes it clear that there are
sub-pieces that are then selected based
on what that heading is
okay so the
key problem with this recipient's
business
gosh
the number one thing here is send to
myself
right right now you have an interface
where i have to type my name here
right
yes
but um
it's stupid it's just stupid i'm sorry
it's just like that's the number one
thing you want the number two issue is
we don't have a way of importing
your i mean the reason that our send
mail stuff
is you know like send notebook to me
doesn't work very well is that we don't
have a way of using
the autocompletes and contacts that
exist on your computer
that's it that's a more general ux issue
i don't know whether john right now it's
a
more general technology issue
okay so it's not exposed in any kind of
is there a way
in which
contacts can get
is there any api in the operating system
that allows you to what's that no
yeah so it's it's a is it an application
by application thing yeah
bluff
and there's no this mappy thing or
whatever it is for for mail
this multi-mail
i mean you know if if the mail server
was properly configured
uh
in wolfram language then
uh then we might be able to query your
address book on your mail server but
that's
that most people do not do that so we we
can't rely on that at all i mean do mail
clients store address books
as in a file that could be pointed to
that's a security problem right i hope
not
yeah i mean
the they do though this isn't a file
but but but which which mail client are
you using which mail client are you
actively using even even if we scrape
your disk which would scare people oh
i'm not suggesting that this be anything
automatic you could say you know load my
if it's not automatic give up well okay
oh well
i suppose well i mean you know you know
back to the earlier thing of you know
most people
and reasonably so don't even configure
uh you know configure the the mail
preferences to do anything other than
the default which is to send through the
cloud if you're logged in and do nothing
if you're not logged in
okay here's a question
maybe this is crazy
you know your mail
we can pull up with a mail to link we
can pull up a piece of mail right a mail
composition window a mail to link will
do that it might be completely wrong but
yeah
but there's a decent chance that
somebody has configured it so that the
mail to link that they hit in a browser
will go to a reasonable mail client if
by decent you mean maybe 25 to 40
percent sure
okay
all right i'll take that so so let's
imagine that there was an interface here
where
you bring up a mail to window
i admit this might seem a little crazy
but you bring up a mail to window and it
sends back to a mail receiver function
address
and
all right this is ornate but but let's
just try it for a second
and then what you do is you fill in the
destination that you want for your mail
using all the auto completion stuff that
you have in your mail client
and you send that to the mail receiver
function
which then
inserts it
into
this
into the actual send to
third-party authentication
like for example you say i want to use
some api from random i don't know from
facebook or something if they've even
got any apis anymore um you know you say
you want to do that you run a piece of
code that does that that says you know
um whatever it is that that says service
connect or whatever right what happens
when you say service connect to facebook
what happens answer it pops
a web page that says now log in to
facebook
you see what i'm saying
it says this is the wolfram connector
um
that is being hosted by
facebook so that you can log in and
authenticate on facebook
as soon as you press the go button the
channel framework is automatically
sucking that data back and using it to
you know uh sort of set up the innards
of the service connection for facebook
so how does your system not send two
emails to the recipients
okay because what happens is that the
mail to link that you are given here
oh i see what you're saying
the only way you get completions is by
typing the names in 2 or cc or bcc which
means you just sent your
funny funny just set the garbage mail to
all your
all your rights okay
okay here's the question yeah is there
any interface all right so a different
solution a much better solution actually
all around will be something if there
was a mail to link
which i'm sure doesn't exist
that if there was a if there was a way
of saying in the mail to link
initiate a piece of mail with this
attachment in it
is that hopeless
well i mean if you could have better
success
having a service connection to like
gmail to contacts so so that's when
you're back to the mappy stuff you know
that's
is that what mapley tries to do
well that's that's in fact what send
mail under windows uh used to do until
we changed it over in
uh
what was it first maybe 11 3 or
something like that
um listen we have to wrap this meeting
uh
i'm not a happy camper with this this
looks like
just this looks like typical
somebody took
you know took a language design and
tried to make an unbelievably
complicated incomprehensible gui out of
it
sorry
i don't can't even imagine what this is
yeah i think that's how the data is
formatted in the body of the email yeah
it's i i don't i can't even imagine it
yeah i i i don't know about this about
the association's business but you know
the rest of the question next aside is
fairly straightforward um for email
though you want to think about do they
they want it association or do they want
to actually be able to read it
like formatted
or do they want or do they want an
attached notebook
because some of the content may be
notebook content unsendable in email
you know what if the person filled in a
a you know a captured video i mean it
just it's just i don't know
i mean your custom action allows them to
do okay but that's not a custom action
is not what we want what we want is for
the thing okay when you say send via
email
i think i know what it does right now
but i think textualizing it is crazy
i think it should just send an attached
notebook
i think it should generate the notebook
and send it
and other things should be maybe we want
and this is why i think having a long i
mean i mean i mean that's that's useless
upon useless
why
well okay so
you have two possibilities you can send
a custom notebook where we're back to
our previous problem you know the all of
the hair around how you customize a
notebook or you can send a default
notebook what is a default notebook a
default notebook is an association it's
just a cell with an association right
it's an expression it's nothing else
i would rather have it in plain text
than have to open the emails well what
happens if there's an image
well in plain text input but but yeah
anything else
well it it it's a it's a wolfram
language expression it will come through
as an image
for better or worse
that's what it will do okay but the
language doesn't have a problem with
this the only people have a problem with
it are us you know okay so i'm gonna
argue
that
the only thing that's useful in email
here
okay why do i even want it in email
okay i don't think it's to read it as a
human i think it is simply because the
plumbing of the world
is such that if you want to get
something to somebody
a good way to send it is through email i
mean i mean look in in my view the
the template notebook case aside
um
in my view
the you know the absolute happy path
is the data bin
but there are some people who are not
going to use database you know maybe
because they have excuse me maybe
because they have uh security and
privacy
issues you know they're they're behind a
firewall and they can't talk to you know
our public data bins and so they need an
alternative
um actually the way the the nicest
alternative will be a mail receiver
function
look if you're using mail as simply a a
you know a way to have tubes
through the world so to speak
then the thing you want to receive to is
ultimately something that processes an
expression
then you have to write a mail receiver
function well and then you might as well
just be putting that function in the
custom action here
no no that's not correct because think
about whose computer it runs on
it can be a cloud deployment api and you
put url executed in the custom function
right but the same thing is
let's look at what the different use
cases one of them passes through
uh you know mail protocols one of them
would just i know i know i know i know
and a question is less likely to make
the stuff the the question is this
you've given out form notebooks
to okay
to the masses so to speak to use right
right
okay let's talk about how they will use
those form notebooks
so one possibility is the form notebooks
are deployed in the cloud
right right if they're deployed in the
cloud
what should come back
is probably cloud objects
in other words what comes back is a an
expression
which
you
well it has to tell you okay so there's
there's three different things going on
number one it has to tell you somebody
submitted something on this form
right that's one thing you don't
necessarily know that a notification
right
thing number two is
give me the thing they submitted
okay
and or get me the thing they submitted
so one way they could submit something
is as a cloud note as a cloud object
because they just through the person who
sent who press submit in the form
notebook what they did is
they had prepared this beautiful
expression which is some kind of
association okay they threw it out there
in the world for somebody to catch
okay so the question is how did they do
the throwing
and how did the catcher catch it and
what did they do with it
right and the catcher
might
on the one hand
you know kind of smart contract like
might want something autonomously to
happen
okay like a mail receiver function like
an api
or they might merely want to be told
okay great it's accumulating good
somebody filled that out
and
you know later they will harvest all the
things that were filled out do you see
what i'm saying so for example it could
be the case that they say
you know so people are filling out a
survey many people fill out the survey
i'm gonna wait until a thousand people
have filled out the survey and then i'm
gonna do big data analysis on it
okay
for which i don't really want an action
taking place immediately i just want
these things these droppings somewhere
of the associations from every every
filling out of that survey
okay so i i claim that in terms of
the how do i throw this the okay how do
i throw the data
one way is you put it in the cloud
okay another way is you send it by email
i another way you might throw the data
is a to a file on your own computer
another thing you might do is to date a
ben to a data bin i i mean you put the
data in an http request
when we talk about the cloud i don't
know why data bin isn't the the first
way to think about this
it's a natural thing
it's not yes
i think it's a natural fit for some
purposes
and and not for others so for example
let's say this is a well maybe it is
maybe it's for everything i don't know
remember
remember database can store arbitrary
wolf and language expressions everything
coming out of here is an association you
keep saying notebook content but it's
all an association well okay fair enough
fair enough fair point fair point
fair point
so you're saying
you're saying that the primary thing
then
is a data bin entry and maybe all the
email is is a notification just like it
is with reports and and if we don't i
don't know if data bins have a
notification feature but that can be a
property of the data bin
right so you're saying it's notification
just like it is for report generation
and for data bins and then we don't even
have an email option here right and we
could
write a resource function that
if we want it to be notebook content
that
creates an api that that you know
collects notebook content and then you
would just have a url executed here that
the resource function gives you to stick
into the custom field
right okay that that might be a nice
workflow yeah i mean let me let me just
re-emphasize i said this before let me
re-emphasize i mean if you're talking
about mass collection
data bin is 100 the natural fit
but there will be some people who simply
can't use databit we do need a backup
for those people right security is
certainly an issue well and also yes if
i'm using this as a personal loop so to
speak i'm just using form notebooks to
fill out you know what i eat every day
and i just want to accumulate it on my
computer and i'm not going to mess
around with data bins and so on
right i mean having put a pen of cloud
object
cloud object is also a very reasonable
thing to do with this
right
so at your case steven i think there's
some value to it but it's territory
value i mean you could have had your own
personal data bin if you you know
you know if you didn't mind wolfe from
having the data so right if i was going
to private cloud if i was going to make
up a third action
besides custom to add to this list it
would be put append to cloud object
which is kind of like databand but then
it's a cloud object in your cloud
account that you can manipulate like a
file anywhere anyhow you want well in in
who's in uh
so the authors the authors
and and
yeah that seems silly to me i mean we've
got data bim which does it essentially
just that
the only problem data bin it's hard to
wrangle the data once it's in there
delete things move things around
if things are messed up it's cool yeah
but it's going to be hard if we give
people the ability to put in a custom
cloud object and they start monkeying
with that cloud object
then there's going to be a list of
associations yeah well i mean
so i mean if if we have a feature
that you know in this case databand that
you know fits 90 of our criteria but it
has a 10 problem let's fix the 10 let's
not implement an entirely parallel thing
yeah that's my view
i'm kind of agreeing with you here i
mean okay
this local loop like the copies of
clipboard and things
is that useful i mean that might be
useful for a lightweight form notebook
that is basically my way of creating
see this is the thing this is the thing
guys this is why the local notebook
thing is useful okay
i've had use cases where this form
notebook is fundamentally a way to just
save me typing let me give you an
example okay give you an example let's
say i want to enter
i've got
random
medical test results that i that got
sent to me in a pdf
okay i want to enter them in a way that
is
well you're saying i
well okay i want to enter them maybe
that's a bad example maybe it's
something which has some images in it or
something like this
i want to enter them
in some way where i can essentially
light weight copy and paste them to put
them in a data structure that i just
have in a notebook right so in other
words i'm using the form notebook
merely
as a
lightweight
structured input mechanism
for something i could otherwise just
type in a notebook
do you see what i'm saying it's a typing
so so so in this case you're creating an
association which maybe you're putting
into a list of associations or yeah but
i'm doing that whatever i just want that
association i'm going to put it in i'm
going to put it in my mouse i'm going to
put it somewhere right i'm not going to
do any elaborate data binning or
anything like that it's just this is
just a saving typing type thing
now i admit
that
form object form functions local form
functions in a notebook do do this kind
of thing and i've never used them for
that
even though there's something i've i've
needed to do many times where i've where
i've got something where i just want to
enter something in a structured way and
i mean i don't even know let's see in
that case yeah in that case they're just
in the output line
i think the problem in that case is this
yes here's the problem with that the
problem is i don't have a peel off
mechanism for the forms for the form
objects what do i mean by that i mean
that what i want to do is
i want 30 times i want to you know do
this little piece of typing structured
typing and generate an association but
what all form object does form function
does in a notebook is it does it once
am i making sense well
uh the uh
uh what happens after it turns into its
result yeah yeah it turns into its
results and that's one page lets you do
it a bunch of times yeah but yeah but
you can't do form page inside a notebook
can you
i think you can
well maybe i don't know i never do it so
i shouldn't click i'm pretty sure you
can yeah well so okay so that's a way to
do that but then then
but then we should use that mechanism
whatever that mechanism is we should
clean that mechanism and be able to use
form notebooks inside form page for
example well and and this comes back to
another issue around form notebooks is
uh you know what happens when you press
the submit button multiple times
um
the uh
uh and and this is potentially a bit
confusing because people might think
that you know maybe they're fixing their
submission when in fact they're
appending to it that should that should
be another thing in this settings menu
to allow repeated submissions so so
yeah so your use case okay you know
wants a repeated
you know actually a comment a comment
from nick on live stream is what about
things like s3 buckets which we have
with external storage
right i mean just as you can send it to
a data bin you could also imagine
sending it to a blockchain s3 all these
kinds of things for which we have code
to do that now is it worth hinting that
you could do that here maybe yes i don't
know
is that custom or is that isn't that
cool i'm not sure yeah it sort of is
right i mean it sort of is and so long
as we can have examples somewhere in
some workflow documentation or something
about doing that then that's probably
reasonable it's a good idea have a dark
page with a bunch of examples and then
link to it from the drop down or next to
the drop down yeah why not
and that way it'll be a workflow page i
think because these are complicated
things that involve external services
um
uh
nikki says various people are commenting
yeah i mean i hope people appreciate
that these things that appear simple are
not as simple as they appear
in terms of creating ux's that aren't
completely crazy
um
and you know
a minimal ux
to make something simple tends to be
very complicated well and and and and
let's be clear the initial
ux which you fairly harshly criticized
but you know that ux was
was guided a lot by a design which upon
closer scrutiny we believe to be
mistaken you know an overall design
you know well i don't know how overall
the design is missing
i mean the issue of the issue of keys
and subjects sub elements was crazy it's
crazy that's what i mean yeah that was
crazy
um but that that was that was difficult
to surmise merely from ux we had to take
a bigger perspective to understand that
indeed which is the usual case in these
situations
all right listen we need to wrap up here
and i'm gosh we're running all sorts of
time problems here um
okay
so there's actually another live stream
for people who are interested it's uh
incremental language development live
stream which will be coming up in a few
minutes but i need to get a bite to eat
before that happens
should start in about 10 minutes i would
say
um
the
um
uh okay good stuff thank you all thanks
to folks on the live stream